welcome back to future chain design this
is pj we often model a lot of uh ladies
ring but not too many of the gentleman
rings so today i would like to dedicate
this video to making this diamond
gentleman ring are you ready let's get
started
[Applause]
for this gentleman ring it's an
interesting design to go from this edges
to be really sharp pointed and coming to
the side to be flat and coming into the
bottom to be flat
so that's starting with this b setting
first you can download this stone for
practice alone the link is in the
description below and what we wanted to
do is to size this stone first the way
to size it is you are going to use the
command for scale 3d and we are going to
snapping into the vertex to the vertex
and then you can
just move your mouse for whatever size
that you want or you can actually type
it the number in my case i want them to
be two millimeter
now when you bring in this stone it may
not be in the right place so we want to
use the command for align centers
and we want to align to the zero point
on the construction plane so just type
in zero then it will coming over here
okay so now let's take a look ideally
you wanted the gap in between the stone
it's about 0.1 to 0.2 millimeter and so
i just want to have a reference here i'm
going to draw a straight line and just
type it 0.1 millimeter so i know the
next stone uh this is will be the gap
for the next stone and that's using the
command for
a linear array
with this linear array i'm going to
use the number maybe seven of them
and then i wanna snapping into the
vertex here and to the endpoint over
there so everybody will have the same
distance let's pick up everybody and
let's group it so now it is a one unit
and we want to use the align
centers
and pick up this one and just type it
zero
so the center
the fourth one will be the center now
let's take a look on the prong for the
prong we are going to do is draw a
straight line something look like this
it doesn't have to be too long in this
case i would like to have a prong that's
eyeball it for whatever size that is
suitable
let's give it a try i want to have a
radius for point
four and see how big is it and see if
you like it now when you have a 0.4 over
there
this one
might be a little bit too big
all right so maybe i want to have it
just a little bit smaller i want to have
a point
35 as my radius
for piping this that's using the pipe
command
and type it 0.35
so we'll have something like this i want
this one right in the middle in between
those and remember we have that line
over there so i'm gonna use the align
tool and align
vertical centers and snapping into the
midpoint there so this is right in the
middle and i want to move in this
prong
so ideally you don't want it to be prone
to be like so tall like that because
then you have a gap in between the wall
and the stone so we want to have
something like this and you also want to
make sure that the prong is not cutting
too much ideally 20 percent of the
thickness will be fine then let's go
ahead to um
making
a mirror and mirror to the other side so
we'll get something like this
and again i'm going to pick up those two
and we are going to use the linear array
and we want to erase seven of them
and again go from this point to
this point so then we'll have the prong
over there
and use a mirror command
type it zero there so we will have a
prong there
at the end of the prong i actually just
need any end of the stone setting i just
need to have one prong there so i'm just
going to again using the align tool this
time align horizontal center and just
type it zero and we can move it out a
little bit
something like this
okay
uh this one just make sure it will be
the same place so it's easier just
mirror again so that's using the mirror
command
type it zero and we'll get something
like this
all right so now we got everything let's
go ahead to make a frame uh we wanted
something a little bit wider than the
stone
doing something like this again we want
this align to the center just type it
zero all right ideally we want this part
to be triangle so that's using the
insert the kink and we want to insert
right in the middle here and we also
write to uh right in the middle here all
right so now if we turn on the control
point we can pick up this point and this
point and also this point this point
simply just one d scale and we can bring
them in like this all right if you feel
like this is too much cutting into the
stone we might need to scale it up like
this
so i'm sorry not cutting into the prong
so we can scale it up something like
this
all right double make sure if this is
what you want i feel like maybe i make
it two pointed
so simply just scale it back up a little
bit like this
all right double make sure this is a
space that you like now we need to have
three row but i also need to make sure
in between the row
there will be a little bit metal left so
let's go ahead to
offset
this curve
and it doesn't need to be too big i
simply just wanted to have a 0.3
millimeter
and if the other row had 0.3 then i will
have
[Music]
0.6 millimeter in between all right so
this is the frame that we have and let's
go ahead to
making a copy so i'm going to copy from
this point to this point
and again i want to copy
all of them
and from this point to this point and
you can make it as many rows possible
you want and by in this case i would
like to have a three row now i'm looking
at the front view realize i did not have
them line up so let's pick up all our
prong and just move it up a little bit
you just need to be have it just a
little bit taller than the table
all right so now it is all set we're
going to move it a bit higher there
let's take a look on the size of the
gentleman ring
the normal size it's about
10 size 10 is the most popular size
average size but for the demonstration
i'm just going to use 16 millimeter just
type in zero here and the diameter for
16 millimeter
okay
and then so this is a little bit wider
than my ring and that's perfect that's
exactly what i'm looking for
okay and that's
starting making the profile for the
bottom of the ring shank i would like to
snapping into the zero using the command
arc
and we are going to
make it a little bit wider here
close to two millimeter and i want to
move in those three points so it's
tapered there okay
so now we have this line let's take a
look on the perspective
all right so we need to have something
like this one need to be continuing
going to the top so i'm actually going
to draw a line snapping into this
endpoint and kind of calm it
down something
look like this all right and
it's a bit ugly right there i know but
we can fix it let's go ahead to trim uh
split this one split command
um we want to
we want to split uh with the point
right at the quadrant there
and then so we can did it half of them
all right for those two let's just go
ahead to join them and we want to
rebuild this curve
i want to rebuild them to be
the same a point
and just hit enter right so you can see
it's get a little bit smoother and
double check if see if this is what you
want
okay so if this is what you want we are
going to creating the surface
now
we have this
it's going to be tapered to the bottom
so i want to see like what button size
to be that's snapping into right here
with the line command line from the
midpoint
uh the icon is leaving right there line
from the midpoint and i want it to be
roughly about
maybe
close to six millimeter
or five millimeter there
on the top i'm actually going to reuse a
certain line so i'm going to reproduce a
line uh make sure your endpoint is on
and i want to snapping into the endpoint
point
bunch of endpoint right there
and then we can pick up this point i'm
going to make it into the red color
all right if you just go ahead to sweep
we're going to slip one rail this is a
rail this is the cross section
and the cross section you're going to
notice that this zigzag shape is going
to go all the way to the bottom when
it's very close to bottom then it will
become flat
but my goal is to having something it's
about right in the
in the half of the shank and they become
flat
so what i like to do is to again using
the
line
from midpoint i'm going to snapping to
somewhere close to the quadrant there
or close to where you want them to be
flat and to be something like this for
whatever size that you want
so that is adding one more control
to make sure that the red z exact shape
will come into the flat and will
continue flat to the bottom of the ring
so let's give it a try we want to use a
sweep one rail this is a rail this is
the cross section this is another cross
section and very last cross section all
right so now we have this but notice
that it is not completely straight all
right but that's okay we can just simply
doing a trim we can just draw a straight
line coming over here
and snapping into this endpoint
and coming over here on my right view
i might just wanted to
trim over something like this
right and you can have this curve
to mirror to the other side
and something like this for those two
then you can trim it off here and trim
it off there so you can have a really
straight line over there all we need to
do now is having this surface that we
just created and coming into the front
view we simply just want to mirror to
the other side
so you will become like that don't
forget to join those two surface
and we just need to close it now to
close this is quite simple
we need her we need to have some curve
so first of all we'll need to have a
curve go from this point to this point
and then we are going to use the command
since they are flat that's using the
surface form planar curve and we're
going to pick up this curve
the one we just draw
this one and this one and we're creating
this surface with this surface coming
into the right view we can simply just
mirror to the other side one more time
and to be like that and don't forget to
join all of them alright so all you have
now uh
left is on the top you need to cap it so
we just wanted to
use the cap and we close it
right now um we have this inside of a
ring shank here the curve is over there
so coming into the solid you got the
extruded planar curve straight
and then you will get something like
this
and don't forget to join the surface
double make sure that see what is this
say here it's a closed solid polished
surface so you need to make sure they
both are solid before you actually
um to do any of the bowling so we want
to do the boolean difference this one
will be out of this one
okay so now we have a basic ring done we
need to have the stone sitting lower if
you have any stone uh stick it out like
this it pretty much will
smash the prong or kind of hurting the
stone on the table so we actually wanted
to do is make sure that the table is
flush with the surface now if you don't
cut any seat out of your stone just bury
inside so i'm going to pick up this
curve
that we created earlier as an interior
and we simply just going to
using this
solid you have extruded planar curve and
then you want to go a little bit deeper
right and then with that we can use the
boolean difference this one will be
uh cut it out for this cutter that we
just created so now the stone was
sitting in there if you take a look on
the render view i mean it felt like they
are sitting directly in there sometimes
it's nice to have a bevel edges that
will make um the reflection to your
storm better and we don't need to have
something really big let's give it a try
all right so we want to transfer the
edges and we want to pick point two
um all over you want to pick make sure
you pick all
the curve at once
and see how it look it looks
pretty nice if you take a render view
now you have this bevel edges there or
what people will call is a bright cut
right so we want to do the same thing uh
coming over to the icon we have the
chamfer edges and we are going to do the
same number on here as well
and pick up this one
this one
and very last one you pick up the here
here here
and here
and don't forget to cut out a c for the
stone um
make sure that you have the um
the
light to go from the bottom and make
sure you have a hole behind the stone
and that will be our gentleman ring for
today's demonstration
i have a lot of uh trick and tips on my
membership program you are more than
welcome to join the membership there's a
lot of
video over there that i only share with
the member thank you for your support
and thank you for watching see you next
you